hello and welcome we have a very special
episode for you today
Tim Kadlec is here from sneaked to talk
about just how insecure much of the web
really is stick around this is the state
of the web all right so Tim thank you
for being here no of course I'm very
happy to be here so let's start with
fundamentals there's so much we could
say about web security and people
usually think about little bobby drop
tables but there's so many more vectors
on the web for attack like then say
sequel injection yeah there's a there's
a large number of different
vulnerabilities I think you know sequel
injection jumps out probably because of
little Bobby drop tables you know but
there's other vulnerabilities that I
think most of us have at least heard in
passing you know cross-site scripting
you know denial of service command
injection the list goes on and on
there's also you know things that people
don't think about like regular
expression denial of service where you
can actually use a regular expression
parsing engine to bring a system to a
crawl there's no shortage of different
vulnerabilities it's just down to how
imaginative the attacker is right and do
you feel like people are aware of all
these different vulnerabilities and more
importantly art do they feel empowered
to actually fix them I think by and
large people have heard at least of the
most common ones you know I pull a room
of developers together they've probably
heard of cross-site scripting they have
krob probably heard of injection maybe
not some of the more obscure ones but at
least those that we've been dealing with
for years and that are the most common
ones they've heard of they may not
realize how many different ways that
vulnerability can be used against them
you know there's an endless amount of
different ways you can inject something
into the page it's not just as simple as
you know injecting a little bit of
JavaScript through either the URL bar or
else you know you can use the base
redirect element you can use malformed
HTML there's it's just you know depends
on the how creative you want to be so I
don't think people are aware of like all
the different ways that those
vulnerabilities can be used but they've
at least heard of them as far as being
empowered that's where the challenge
comes in because traditionally security
has been that other thing right it's the
other security team has to deal with
this a separate team that sits somewhere
else within the organization
have their own tools they have their own
process you know they do their own audit
and maybe report back to the developers
on things they need to fix maybe in the
best of cases they've had a tool that
they've picked out and then told the
developers they have to conform or use
this tool the challenge has been that we
haven't treated security as something
that the everyday developers should be
focusing on and we haven't given them
the tools and the time and the process
to deal with that at least not until
recently we're starting to get a little
better but we have a ways to go right so
what could a developers say if they're
getting pulled in one direction from
their manager let's say to just ship the
feature but if they're being told that
the feature development takes precedence
over security what could they say to
bring them back down to earth I mean
that's a challenge if they don't have
buy-in already from the organization in
terms of focus on security it's going to
be very challenging for them to do I
think that's the first thing you have to
do is you have to make sure that you are
you've taken the time to do with some
risk assessment you know this is the
application that we're using this is the
way our company works and these are all
the different things that could possibly
go wrong and if they go wrong this is
how bad it could be and then from that
you determine like okay well based on
this information we absolutely have to
make sure our data is stored securely we
absolutely have to be on HTTPS you
identify these three or four things that
are at the very top of the list and you
start to track those you know find some
tools that will do reporting throw it in
a dashboard make them a priority find
ways to enforce them in the development
process if you put those things in there
to help provide this sort of protection
or this extra layer of support I guess
to the developers so it's not just one
developer going to their manager and
saying hey this is really bad for a
security that's not going to get you
very far but if you say look you know
we've identified as our organization
we're tracking that we don't want to be
vulnerable on any properties using HTTP
we want to HTTPS Everywhere and if you
look we've got this issue here or so on
with the code you know for cross
scripting or whatever it happens to be
that carries a lot more weight if it's
already backed and supported by other
people within the organization so a
developer can be so careful with code
that they write
in-house to make sure that it doesn't
have any of those from vulnerabilities
but
it's the third party JavaScript that
they pull in that could really come back
to bite them you've actually done some
research into this space with your
company sneaked the 2017 state of
open-source security report says that
four hundred and thirty three thousand
websites tested out of those
seventy-seven percent have at least one
JavaScript vulnerability which is crazy
right
like seventy-seven - Centuri number yeah
so what can developers actually do to
mitigate that well okay so first off
it's worth noting that you know these
are JavaScript vulnerabilities there
specifically JavaScript vulnerabilities
in known like libraries right these are
vulnerabilities that we know about that
we've documented and that the library is
something that's being shared typically
through NPM or something like that so
there could be much more vulnerabilities
floating out there that we just haven't
discovered yet we're defining new known
vulnerabilities every single day
literally I yeah it's very scary as well
as this doesn't tell you about the
vulnerabilities that might be lurking in
this stuff you've produced yeah it's it
comes down to that open source
development is so fantastic right it I
think it's awesome that we have this
vibrant ecosystem this community of
people who are willing to you know
create a library that solves a problem
and then put it out there so other
people can use it there's a reason why
this is massively popular within
organizations because it makes so much
sense to tap into the collective
intelligence of thousands of developers
rather than trying to build everything
in-house and repeat you know the
rebuilding of the wheel every single
time you need some piece of
functionality but yeah we don't
necessarily know who those people are
let's assume that you have a JavaScript
library let's assume that on average
maybe five to ten people contribute to a
single JavaScript library I think that's
a fairly conservative number for like
the smaller stuff you're probably
talking into a couple but on some of the
bigger projects like react or jQuery you
have tons of contributors that means
that if you're pulling in ten different
libraries that you're using in your
application you're trusting in 100
different developers ten developers per
library a hundred developers that you're
saying I'm trusting what they know about
security I'm trusting that they've taken
the time to watch for the security
issues and the code that they're
producing that they're not just putting
it out there I'm trusting their security
how that's a really long chain of trust
and so there's a lot of risk that's
inherent in that so we have to be really
careful and really critical when we
evaluate what libraries we're using to
make sure that there aren't these
security issues lurking in them so what
is the threat level here should we be
scared what is the severity of these 77%
should be terrified it depends so so 77%
is you know it's certainly a large lot
larger than I expected when we're first
was digging into this I was expecting
that we were gonna see about 30 percent
so certainly the number itself is scary
right that's a ton of sites with at
least one in the armor
however the severity of those
vulnerabilities do vary so you have
things that range from low severity
vulnerabilities where there's not much
that's going to happen something can go
wrong but it's not necessarily an
ultimate disaster too high severity
vulnerabilities like if they're able to
do some sort of injection or command
injection injection and get some
arbitrary commands to run on your site
or application that's obviously a really
big deal so it varies in terms of
severity the other thing to keep in mind
is that we don't know how many of these
vulnerabilities are exposed we can test
and we can see that these
vulnerabilities exist we know that a
vulnerable library is being used but
some of these vulnerabilities apply to a
specific method for example there's a
jquery vulnerability that applies only
if you're making an ajax request for
json data if you're not doing something
like that you're okay
so it really comes down to an individual
assessment it depends on the
organization how are they using these
libraries what's at stake if something
does go wrong but again that requires
that risk assessment and that critical
thinking you know if you're pulling in a
library and you see it's got a known
vulnerability how likely is it that that
vulnerability is going to be used
against you and what's the worst that's
going to happen if somebody does it and
it's also worth keeping in mind too that
just because you're not vulnerable today
to that like you're not using that
method today it's still there it's a
weakness in the framework of the library
so two months down the road a developer
who's not aware that this is an issue it
comes in and uses this method and
suddenly you're exposed again you know
it's not developers don't want to have
to sit there in second doubt themselves
every single
time that they're pulling in one of
these libraries and using a method
that's not what should happen so it's
very dangerous to keep the weakness
around so I guess going back to like how
scared should we be we should be
uncomfortable with it for sure but I
don't know if we should be running out
of the building because it's on fire
kind of scared I think you know it's
definitely a fixable problem so let's
step into the methodology for a second
how do we arrive at this 77% sure so
what we ended up doing is so sneek
maintains a database of known
vulnerabilities across a bunch of
different ecosystems for Java Script
it's a lot of NPM libraries so what we
were able to do is we're able to take a
snapshot of that database specifically
for client-side libraries or frameworks
and then we compare that with there's a
fantastic Chrome extension the
JavaScript library detector there's
actually the detection part of that this
script has been put out on NPM for
people to be able to pull into their own
applications and it goes through you
know 60 I think it'll a sty looks
somewhere around there different
libraries where it'll detect the
presence of that library and the version
of it programmatically which is great
because you're not relying on URLs or
anything that's gonna have all sorts of
you know mishaps you're actually
programmatically detecting if it exists
so using that we can run this inside of
in this case lighthouse in lighthouse
when it put opens the page it'll run
that javascript detection which gives it
a report of all the different libraries
that it finds and then those different
libraries are checked against the
sneaked database to see if we know that
there was a vulnerability for that
specific version of that library and
then that's how we end up with the final
vulnerability count so in terms of the
size of the test that's thanks to HTTP
archive so we can test over hundreds of
thousands of different sites and quickly
see you know how what libraries they're
using and if there was a vulnerable or
not and one of the nice things about
HTTP archive is that it's continuously
running semi-monthly right so we can see
how that 77 percent changes over time
and actually looking at some recent data
it's taken kind of a dip by two percent
we went from 77 to 75 in December back
up to 77 now so what might be some of
those reasons for fluctuations I mean
some variability right like in terms of
a fluctuating down that's gonna be a
little less calm and I think you know
that's going to come down to if
something went wrong with the HTTP
archive runs or maybe the JavaScript
detection the script something changes
inside that script that causes for a
little while a library not to be
reported correctly and so it misses some
of those so that you know it's gonna
fluctuate a little bit like the one or
two percent I guess is not as big a deal
overall I think it's probably gonna
trend up unfortunately it just depends
it's gonna be a race in terms of
developers who are addressing the
problem versus how many more
vulnerabilities do we find you know
we've added a couple vulnerabilities
since you know this first shift that
make the the database of known
vulnerabilities that lighthouse is
checking against bigger so we're
catching more than before and the
library detector script is also getting
more accurate so it's detecting for
example when it shipped initially there
was an issue with react being detected
and now that's been fixed so the
percentage of vulnerable react apps have
probably gone up a little bit so if
anything I would expect it to fluctuate
a little high but you'll see some dips I
guess depending on how things go so Tim
thank you so much for being here I've
learned a lot and I'm frankly scared by
some of the things you've told me I need
to go and fix my own website now it's
always a pleasure to terrify people so
thank you so if you have a question for
Tim or any pro tips on how you secure
your own website leave a comment below
and thank you for watching the state of
the web we'll see you next time
[Music]